hi Roger here from Google cloud and in
this video we'll have a look at pay
later and its relation to open banking a
sample implementation of the API and the
wider picture of consuming and
publishing api's open banking is a
system of allowing access and control of
consumer banking and financial accounts
through third-party applications it
encourages interoperability between
banks and consumers by making available
to bank's core services and accelerating
their digital transformation first we'll
show you a common use case and then
we'll unpack it for you we'll start with
the end-user experience an API consumer
in this case a merchant and e-commerce
industry offering last minute Chromebook
deals
develops a new app experience using
Google Assistant let's have a look talk
to pixel book deal store hi welcome to
the pixel VIP deals store what can I do
for you are there any special offerings
here you go you selected pixel book 16
gigabytes ram costing 854 pounds would
you like to pay now or pay later hey
later okay now choose the bank yeomen
after login to your bank I need to link
your pixel verb deals store account to
Google is that okay yes when your
account was linked to Google the app can
customize your experience based on your
identity financial data or
authentication data cannot be collected
via the conversational interface so
we're now shown terms and conditions for
pay later and there's a link to review
those conditions simply click on it and
then return to the deal page when ready
here's a sample reference to a terms and
conditions page whenever we're ready you
can go back to the main screen and say
all good
we now see some of the loan offers to
pay later we can scroll up and still
reference to terms and conditions if we
want to once we're ready we'll select
the desired loan okay that's it
see Stevie I strap these families in to
keep from their tuition speech you buy
and fill now we've looked at this from
the perspective of a merchant leveraging
the banks pay later api's to improve the
checkout experience how do we get access
in the first place
stepping back to look at the wider
picture there are more actors involved
to get it all working first the bank
wants to share a service in this case
the pay later API but still maintain
some restrictions such as applying a
column in second it's the merchant who
is asking for access to those api's in
order to build better apps
third it's api product managers within
the organization who treat api's as
products and therefore are looking at
publishing easy onboarding content and
getting an overview of the usage
statistics now we'll have a look at how
a developer can find those api's in this
case as API consumer again here's a
sample developer portal of the bank
which allows anyone to browse through
the API catalog here we're already
logged in as an app developer with a
partnering organization in this case the
merchant and the first thing a developer
typically does is build a developer
application we already have here the
deal finder assistant previously created
upon approval of the bank you receive
credentials namely an API key and secret
to access this pay later API very often
developers want to test this API and
want to see what their responses or how
to embed it in the application we can go
into the pay later API specification and
we can see all the different paths and
operations
under loan payment and refund we can
send a test request for that first of
all we have to authorize we select the
app from before and authorize that the
API key credentials be stored now we can
enter some consumer ID and some payment
resource identification and execute the
call this will return a payload and give
a developer an overview of how the API
works as you can see Apogee helps
accelerate the publishing of api's
making them ready for consumption while
keeping an eye on where they're being
used all in all this shows what's
possible beyond open banking namely the
opportunity to build new customer
channels with more control over the data
developers and partners to create a
connected experience this enhances
interoperability between traditional
banking data with an API ecosystem
thanks for listening in and feel free to
read more about our open banking
solution and what Apogee provides for
api's and financial services at the link
listed in the description below
[Music]